Even though the overall equation is simple, there's two things to be careful about.
First, you cannot write 1/3 because that would be 0.
Integer divided by integer would be an integer so you have to put in at least one decimal point here.
The second thing to be careful about is Python's power operator.
If you forget the parenthesis here, it would be forming the first power
and would be dividing the result by 3, which is not what we want obviously, and here's the result.
If you start with an initial value of 0, the results stays at 0 all of the time,
but if we start with a positive number that's ever so slightly above 0, such as 10⁻³⁰⁰,
we get a completely different evolution
and as you can see, there's hardly any difference between starting with 10⁻³⁰⁰
and starting with 0.01.
From a numerical view point, this differential equation looks as though
0 is a highly unstable fixed point.
Once you get a tiny bit above 0, the solution is going to quickly divert from that
and mathematically speaking, this is a differential equation whose solution curves are not unique.
If you start with 0, you will branch off at any point in time in this fashion and get another solution.